not many people have written a memoir by
age 25 but this gentleman's memoir fear
is a choice more chapters yet to be
written but the chapters already in it
tell an incredible story that I'm
thrilled that he is bringing to the Rich
Eisen show right now he is Pittsburgh
Steelers running back James Conner how
are you sir
doing great rich Thank You feble me man
I am pleased to have you on here right
now let's start first before we get to
the book the viral video I saw this I
got misty I got all choked up you know
fathers days coming up in about three
days time you posted a video I'll give
you the floor right here we're watching
it right now it's you and your dad tell
me what this tell everyone this video is
right now that they're seeing James yeah
my dad
DMC pickup truck that's what you can
walk in for a while now just happy I'm
in a position that I that I you know
happy and blessed but I'm a position
where I can do that for him yeah
surprising I got the idea from a sumo
team septillion Donald he I bought his
data truck and his reaction was
priceless and so I let me do the same
and so he record my day even in the
truck in his reaction was priceless so
now I'm just a guy can hold on to that
um he was just so stock to try to give
me the keys well you know the thing that
got me emotional is not only you know
just seeing your father enjoying you
know obviously something that he wants
he could ride around and and and it's a
you know that that's incredible in its
own right but I know your story James
and that's what this book is all about
and I just you know I get emotional
thinking about what your father must
have been going through when you were
going through your diagnosis with
Hodgkin's lymphoma and wondering about
your health and your future and your
ability to stay alive let alone have a
career where this could be bought for
him that's what got me James yeah you
know it goes a lot deeper than just a
gift you know so this is the backstory
to it and what things could have been
and how things turned out beautiful so
yeah it's definitely much more than me
just getting him a truck it's you know a
lot of things he overcame and now that
you know emotions for must be
in that moment you could say how we were
interacting and stuff so it was special
what's your dad's name James grant
Oakland Connor so what was your family's
role in in helping you through when you
call them up you're in the middle of a
college career at Pittsburgh and you
call him up at age 20 and say I have
some news yes that was that was the
hardest part about the whole process and
even during the process of writing my
book um brief revisiting those days you
know it's tough that was the hardest
thing about it you know I'm the youngest
of four five I got four older brothers
and you know just calling them my old
life they had always been a wanted to do
anything for me had my back through
anything
you know I ever went through you know it
with this it's probably not much they
can do you know so that was that was the
hardest part about it all was breaking
the news because all my family my like
my teammate but the role of their role
they would just let me know keep going
strong keep my faith strong with this
constant encouragement from from a close
circle and also people on the world I
received so many messages from people
who've reached out and just sent their
well wishes and prayers I surely
wouldn't have gotten through it with
without the support of everyone James
Conner here on the Rich Eisen show
describe why you call your memoir what
you called it fear is a choice James I
believe that is human nature to have
fear but but we also have choices in
decisions that we can make and we have
to make every day and so on you know
fear is kind of the same form as you
could say adversity and it's really hard
to escape adversity I mean whether it's
I'm is happened to be cancer but there's
you know there's a death in the family
or hardship laid off in your job you
know they're the reason I have fear that
was also a reason to believe that you
can be better because of this adversity
and come out on the side better so I
know people get scared of things out of
time but you have the opportunity to see
their fear door or go after it when did
you realize that I imagine unless that
was the first thing that went through
your mind which by the way would be
remarkable for a 20 year old but when
did you realize that it was a choice I
think in the middle of it I mean that
you know it was actually the hardest
things I've had to do with you know
before
that I had my knee injury that my for my
MCL you know a couple months prior to
that version of town state beginning of
my junior season and so you know my fake
that's wrong because had I not for my me
I would run the field and if it went you
know very very wrong so with having any
interesting in the game of football and
teaches you life lessons and so I was
just in that moment and I you know that
my first treatment so I my second
treatment I had I had ten more to go I
said I can do ten more at even you know
that content encouragement and
positivity that I said I kissed uh you
know push through well it's kind of a
rare thing to James that you you can
also potentially although you probably
would know at the time whatever
motivation you might have needed to
continue on and follow your pro career
dreams that the team that eventually
drafted you was right there in front of
your face right and yeah I think that's
the beautiful thing about the University
of Pittsburgh you know we share a
facility and on this story I already
just can't make it up you know the city
I played my college ball in and then get
healthy in and then play for that
protein it's kind of just a social
surreal night and I thought I know my
life is in God's hands because I can't
ignore it itself and the ways playing
out so far I hope it didn't stop you
know blessed continue to coming and so
with me
yeah happen my ultimate goals I wanna
hang on to and what I want to achieve in
life like I see them practicing and I
see how they go about their business
that was that the motivation for me to
just look at this cancer as a bump in
the road and I'm still chasing my dream
and I want to get for these guys the
right that I'm seeing every day when's
the first time you met Mike Talman was
the first time you cross passes and
James you remember you know so ever
since you know like even freshmen will
be on the field and working off the
field the Steelers will be coming on and
I think the first interaction was after
my sophomore year you knowing him just
telling me good game last night um so I
was like the first interaction that we
had but you know he says that you may
use like I've been watching you since
you've been at sis
so he's had eye on me for a little while
so it's a good thing that used it yeah
it's a good
I guess so to have a front-row seat for
what you were going through and then you
get drafted but you get drafted by a
team that's got somebody that's sitting
there in front of you on the depth chart
who had already made quite a name for
himself and certainly in that city in
levy on bail when he held out James um
what did you think of first when you
heard people say well that's the end of
that for the Pittsburgh Steelers cuz
love's not there oh yeah when he's only
first was holding out it was actually my
rookie year and he I came we maybe
didn't come to training campus and he I
came on scene started not thought the
same thing was gonna happening for a
year too but I was just telling myself I
said I had no control over this I'm just
going to continue to try to get my body
in the best shape and be ready and
prepared like I am the starter just in
case if there's some reason he didn't
show up that I was at that starting job
but I was prepared either way if he was
gonna come in like you said he already
had a name for himself he had earned
that you know you've done great things
for that team so he what it came my
second year you know I just played my
role but um he ended up not showing up
in after the other a good little season
so I was just preparing like I was going
to start either way how many people told
you that year that when you ran into
them that you won them your fantasy
league oh yeah that's the only thing I
heard you go anywhere without without
somebody saying you know I did that and
I wanted to save them all fantasy and
all that it was a lot of I'm sure you
heard all that James Connors the
Steelers here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about the hearing now what
are you hearing about a playing season
for 2020 right now James you expecting
it really wondering about it how would
you tell that right now kind of kind of
everything um you know we're stuck
waiting here on decisions that you know
the league is making about they're gonna
be fans or season is gonna start on time
what we're gonna do with preseason games
so there's really you know we're kind of
just playing it by ear I haven't heard
much I hope we can start on time you
know mission to get back in and get back
just playing football and being around
my teammates and just getting back into
the swing of things but we have to take
off you know precaution is necessary and
I'm staying ready but I hope we get back
so I'm grabbing her
about it well I mean are you technically
somebody who is more vulnerable to this
virus because of your history with
Hodgkin's lymphoma are you somebody that
would be in a high-risk group or have
already been told no you know I was
talking to my doctor and he we were
talking in you know I'm going on four
years now from from being cancer-free
so you know my immune system is backed
up strong and healthy you know came up
ran its course and that's all allowed
it's all done so I'm still going to play
it safe and and and do it families do
but as far as me being more vulnerable
no because I'm healed well that's
wonderful news there but in terms of
again just are you're expecting like to
hear when at any point in time about a
report date what are you expecting on
that James well we usually report to
camp around late July July like 26
through you know 30 or 30th anywhere
between those days and so I'm hoping we
can get back to that but other you know
nothing is said don't
and then more in real life as if
pandemics not enough we're seeing what's
going on in our world in our society
certainly with police brutality and
social justice and racial justice for
all and I'm hearing so much about so
many moving conversations amongst
teammates and certainly with team
meetings having a lot of conversations
on this subject to have the Steelers had
that yeah we we've been on our team
meetings and discussing things and
trying to put a plan in place and
definitely acknowledging it in and
trying to figure out how we can then
move forward and and make change and so
long it's definitely a topic of
discussion for us instead of the [ __ ]
with teammates and we're trying to put a
plan in place to continue to spread
awareness and make a difference in this
country because but we need okay so in
terms of an action plan that's been
discussed what about a plan in terms of
a visual protest a peaceful protest we
know obviously that has been a subject
back in 2017 with this team and the
conversations that were had and what the
locker room felt about it I mean this
in particular I'm wondering if there's
any conversation that's been had on that
front you can share with us James the
conversations are still and in
discussion you know so we're definitely
gonna continue to we're not we know
we're all with the movement and we're
all ready to make change and bring
awareness so we don't have a set plan
but we're definitely talking about it in
and seeing what's the best way to go
about this and so we can't so we can
make a difference well James I
appreciate the time Congrats on the book
you know there's more chapters to be
written right oh yeah okay yeah I mean
you got no this is just I mean there's
different versions you can you can you
can write an addendum you can do all
there's a paperback version that you
could you know talk about you're rushing
championship year all that sort of stuff
right all right yeah I'm on board with
you you know so we have we got more to
talk about there's more more things on
our way so I like to think that we're
just going to start well enjoy your
Father's Day weekend although upon
hearing the fact that there were five
boys in the house I have to say the
Mother's Day is also crucially important
oh yes so let's not forget mom but again
I don't know that video of is your dad
riding around who's you'd like what was
the first Rod what's going on tell me
what tell me the PostScript on this
truck oh no I hate accept expresses to
me you know how much it meant to him and
how much he loved it
you know so you know he's riding around
it and he said you get all these
compliments you know he's looking like a
slur within the area back home so I'm
proud of him happy for him yeah or is
they still in Erie is that where they
are yeah my father okay James thanks for
the call Congrats again on the book fear
is a choice everybody should go get it
right now available we're all books are
sold and let's chat when you know
hopefully everything opens up and you
got a playing season and let's let's
reconnect then James okay thank you
always a pleasure that's James Connor